all right so you've done the hard yards
you've made the design from scratch
you've spent hours on end perfecting
your design and making it exactly how
you want now it's time to export your
design in archicad 25 and be able to
actually showcase it and print it if you
want to follow along with this tutorial
i'll link it above just so you can
actually go back and recreate this if
you want but if you're simply just
trying to actually export whatever
you've documented in archicad then
follow along here we're going to start
by going to our layout book on the right
hand side of our navigator we want to be
using the view map to be able to
actually define what we need let's say
we're going to use our architectural
plans we're going to use our ground plan
so if we double click on that we'll see
that this is our ground floor plan the
same goes for our sections and
elevations than anything else we've
created so in this point in time i'm
simply going to go command d move all of
those roughly somewhere over here so
that we have elevation sections and
everything cutting through the building
as if we were actually documenting this
project step by step now if we come
across to our layout book you'll see
that predominantly we already have a
million and one things already set up
now you can go ahead and use any of
these over here to actually create what
you want i have personally created my
own archicad 25 layout book title blocks
if you want to check them out they're in
the description below but for today
we're just simply going to use the
generic export on the right hand side
now i'm going to start by creating a
whole new layout instead of going
through and using their typical layouts
just to show you exactly how the process
works so if we click on a new layout
we're not going to include it in any
automatic numbering sequences we can if
we want so let's go do not include we're
going to create a custom number a double
zero and we're going to call it the
layout we'll use our a1 landscape title
block for the purpose of this and simply
click create now that you can see it's
automatically created our a double zero
layout which for this instance let's say
we want that to be our architectural
site plan so if we click drag and let go
of our site plan we'll see that our site
plan has been automatically updated and
placed in to this elevation if we then
click on one of the external bounding
boxes we can see that we activate our
offset edges and we can slowly drag out
our site plan to the full size of this
page right click update once more to see
that we've got everything actually shown
on our page if we click on this black
dot once again and then move our sub
element it'll allow us to move the
actual image inside of that view window
rather than manipulating the view window
itself so let's just simply center that
for the time being next we're going to
repeat the same step going new layout do
not include this layout in the sequence
a01
and create and we have our next page we
can repeat that same step by going to
our ground floor plan and repeating that
step a couple more times to create
sections and elevations so i've created
two more layout books there in my
elevations i'm going to hold shift drag
all four of these across it's
automatically going to update them and
place them smack bang in the middle so
then all we have to do is adjust our
edges so we can actually create that
and have it exactly where we need to be
so we don't have to showcase too much
information that we don't need drag them
onto our page where they can fit and as
you can see now we can see our 3d color
elevation cutting through our earth
showing our grass hatch above our stone
our glass and our building obviously
there's a lot more information that
needs to go on to these drawings to be
any use to anybody in the real world but
this is just an export example finally
we can do the same thing over here for
our sections so we've got two sections
that we can drag and drop onto this pdf
adjust our settings as required command
d
move them to the center and there we
have our two sections started as we've
drawn it now you would have noticed that
i created these as individual numbered
elements so if we don't want to have to
go back and individually change these
one by one so as an example if i change
that moved it above whatever other page
i wanted it doesn't automatically
renumber them we can select all those
pages right click layout settings let's
untick this box here let's use the
automatic book settings and let's go
okay so you'll see it automatically
changes the numbering system 0 1 2 3 and
if i was to move that one below that one
it would renumber them you can also
rename these individually so go rename
layout change the layout name to
elevations because that's what it is so
you know what it is so now it makes a
bit more sense so if i drag this site
plan above that ground floor plan you'll
see that automatically numbered if you
want that automatic numbering to be a
little bit different a little bit more
applicable to how you wish to number
them we can right click on our book
settings and we can change our setting
style so let's say we want to have an a
in front we want to use double letters
instead of single click ok you'll see
all of those update automatically to the
a
a0010203 system now if you have no idea
what any of that does if we scroll into
the bottom corner of each page you'll
see that it has actual information so
ground floor plan a01 elevations a02 and
it relates to that information so when
you're flicking through a printed set
you know exactly what page people are
referring to now to export these four
pages of the pdf there's a couple
different steps we can take one of the
simplest ways is to highlight all of the
pages you wish to export by holding
shift clicking on the first and clicking
on the last going file save as let's
save that to the desktop change this to
a pdf file go document options selected
layouts in navigator making sure that
they're in color clicking ok
and then renaming to example export
let's open this file after we've done so
we can just see what it's actually
created so as you can see now it's
exported this pdf document exactly like
we saw in the archicad model we have all
our pages individually named
individually numbered that you can print
share or do whatever a second
alternative that has a little bit more
control a little bit more flexibility
and also at the same time a little bit
more of a foolproof system when you're
coming back to a drawing set so you know
exactly what pages you exported before
if we click on our project overview here
go show organizer we don't need this
batch renderer for the time being so i'm
going to delete that and go new folder
let's go example export 2
and then i'm going to drag and drop all
four of these files into that example
export too if we right click on that
example publishing properties saving
that just directly to our desktop and
clicking ok so then we can click ok
again
merge all to one pdf or you can leave
that unticked so you can have individual
pdfs some builders prefer to have
individual pdfs some people like to
export as one booklet and simply
clicking the publish button when you're
completed if i close both of those there
minimize my window i can see example set
two over here and we'll see that we've
exported exactly the same thing with
just a little bit more control anyway
that's all for me today guys thank you
so much for watching i hope you enjoyed
the video if you did make sure you smash
the subscribe button and like always
i'll see you next monday